- [Daniela] In response
to the coronavirus crisis,
researchers are working
at a breakneck pace
to develop solutions
that will allow economies
to reopen safely and permanently.
- Without an effective vaccine,
we won't be able to get
this pandemic under control
and stop the devastation
that it's currently causing
all around the globe.
- Vaccines can take an average
of 10 years to develop,
according to a 2013 study,
but researchers and
pharmaceutical companies
are hoping to bring
their vaccine candidates
for the new coronavirus to
market in 12 to 18 months.
Some are even talking about getting
Emergency Use Authorizations
before the end of the year.
So what is making it possible
to expedite this process so dramatically?
There are several factors,
including prior knowledge
of coronaviruses,
specifically SARS and MERS,
improvements in sequencing
of viral genomes,
advancements in
bioengineering technologies,
unprecedented government
support and funding,
plus a shortened testing timeline.
Traditionally, after scientists
develop a vaccine candidate,
they run it through a series of tests.
This starts in cells, and
then transitions to animals,
usually beginning with mice
and eventually progressing to monkeys.
Testing only advances
from one phase to the next
if it's proven to be safe and effective.
- At that stage, you
would then likely perform
what we call a challenge study,
so that would be vaccinating an animal
then intentionally giving them the virus
and seeing the impact of your
vaccine on that disease model
where, of course, you
would hope to protect it.
- Then they'd use that data to
get approval from regulators
like the FDA to begin human testing.
There are three stages of human trials,
each one testing more
people than the last.
Approval is required for each stage.
Instead of this relay approach
where researchers wrap up
each set of experiments
before embarking on the next round,
developers are now doing
many tests in parallel.
- So we're not skipping
steps, but we're doing things
at the same time, which
of course costs a lot more
and is a lot more work than
doing it one after the other,
and that's the key difference.
- The novel coronavirus was
discovered and sequenced
less than six months ago.
Several candidates are already
in phase one of human trials,
including those made by Inovio and Pfizer,
even as companies await
results from animal studies.
Moderna recently started phase two.
Others are gearing up for phase two
before phase one wraps up.
- Our phase one trial will run for a year,
but we're not going to wait
for that full year period
to have elapsed before
we hopefully move on
to the next stage of efficacy testing.
- Because of the worry of
COVID-19 being so devastating,
we are expediting those processes,
and this oughta concern,
because we don't really know
all that much about
immunity to this virus,
that we may be going too quickly,
but so that's the balance here.
- [Daniela] Vaccines
work on a simple premise.
They trick the body into thinking
a virus has infiltrated it
so the immune system kicks into action
and starts producing
antibodies and other defenses
against parts of the virus.
In this case, scientists
think their target
is the spike protein,
which the coronavirus uses
to get into cells.
- It's been shown from SARS and MERS
that the spike protein
is the major protein
on the outside of the virus
of these coronaviruses
to which erase neutralizing antibodies,
and neutralizing
antibodies is what you need
to fight the infection.
- So what would really end the pandemic
is when there's enough
immunity in the population,
and either than immunity
comes from everybody getting infected
or it comes from a vaccine,
and it's a much gentler path
for everybody to get a vaccine
than for everybody to get infected.
- [Daniela] This concept
is known as herd immunity.
Dozens of companies and labs
are trying various technologies
to develop vaccines that
would get us there quickly.
Scientists say it's the largest,
most collaborative
vaccine development effort
they've seen in their lifetimes.
They're testing four main strategies,
weakened viruses, proteins,
viral vectors, and genetic code vaccines.
Weakened or inactivated virus vaccines
are the most common.
That's your annual flu shot.
We have the most experience with these,
but they can also be costly
and time-consuming to mass-produce,
so in this case, they haven't
been the preferred approach.
Protein-based vaccines
carry key parts of the
virus into the body.
For coronavirus, that's the spike protein.
Sanofi and GlaxoSmithKline
are among dozens of developers
taking this approach.
For viral vector vaccines,
scientists use an inactivated
virus and stuff it
with the genetic code
for the spike protein,
which our cells then use
to turn out viral proteins.
The immune system then
recognizes those as foreign.
Johnson & Johnson is
developing this type of vaccine
for the coronavirus.
- [Gert] We use adenovirus vector,
and this adenovirus is a common cold virus
which normally doesn't
cause any major disease,
just a common cold.
In the adenovirus, it becomes
replication incompetent.
- [Daniela] In the
fourth and final category
are genetic code vaccines.
These contain the instructions
for the spike protein.
COVID vaccines being developed by Inovio,
Pfizer, and Moderna
fall into this category.
These types of vaccines
have never been approved
for humans before,
but they're generating
a lot of excitement.
- The reason we're seeing them
out in front is the speed.
- The speed in the manufacturing
and the development?
- Yeah, really, both.
Proteins are more diverse.
They have all kinds of different shapes
and characteristics and so you
have to play with a lot more
to actually get a
protein-based vaccine made.
- [Daniela] Pfizer is
running multiple candidates
through phase one trials
in the U.S. and Germany
to cut down on development time.
- And even before we know
whether the vaccine works or not,
we're starting to ramp
up manufacturing capacity
so that we're ready to make it right away.
The key things you have to
establish to develop a vaccine
are that it is safe, that it's effective,
and that every time you make
it, it comes out the same,
so those key steps don't change
whether you're going fast
or you're going slow.
- Changes in manufacturing can
introduce unforeseen issues
that could make a vaccine dangerous.
That's what happened with
the since-discontinued
polio vaccine decades ago.
Safety is a major concern,
because vaccines are
given to healthy people,
so scientists have to ensure
they don't affect things
like liver or heart function
among other factors.
There are other issues as well.
Even if companies are able
to come up with a vaccine
in less than two years, the
vaccine research community
is concerned with how they'd be able
to produce and distribute it
to everybody on the planet.
- So we are aiming to
produce one billion dose
by the end of 2021, and
some other companies
are committing to the same kind of scale,
either hundreds of millions or billions,
but still, it will not
be enough for everyone.
- What is a big unknown
is what the durability
of that protection is.
Is it going to be a year, two years,
or even maybe, unfortunately,
six months or less,
because if it is measured
in several months
instead of years, which
is entirely conceivable
that that would be the case,
then we have a secondary problem.
How often do you need to boost somebody
to keep that level of immunity up?
- [Daniela] The final and
perhaps most important hurdle
for coronavirus vaccine
development will be human behavior.
- Are people gonna be
accepting of this vaccine?
That's been such a huge
problem in this country.
You know, if you have 50% of people
saying I'm not gonna take
it under any condition,
then, of course, you've
lost the whole battle.